hace 20 años cuando una nube espesa de
polvo cubrió nueva york- unos 3.000
migrantes indocumentados latinos se
prestaron como voluntarios para limpiar
la devastada zona zero como esta
colombiana que trabajó durante 8 meses
en la limpieza de los edificios
colindantes al world trade center sentir
la necesidad de ayudar no estaba
ayudando aquí
venir a la rescatada a ver que podía
hacer
por eso muy importante me sentía sentía
que tenía que estar aquí
trabajamos en el robot se encontró se
encontrará cuerpos también pero a su vez
zapatos en 2001 un 27 de la población
newyorkina era hispana tras los
atentados muchos migrantes
indocumentados ayudaron en la limpieza
de las 18 toneladas de escombros con la
promesa de legalizar su estatus uno se
ofreció a ir a trabajar una preguntaron
dos décadas después la decepción es
evidente la comunidad latina te enteras
que nos iban a ayudar porque yo creo una
cosa de verdad que estoy muy
discriminada algunos fueron deportados y
algunos de nuestro grupo dijeron no
mejor yo irme si es que voy a morir
mejor me voy para mi país por lo menos
estoy con mi familia por lo menos tengo
un techo además en ese momento nadie era
consciente de los peligros para la salud
que acarreaba la exposición al polvo
tóxico que como se demostró más tarde
derivó en graves enfermedades
respiratorias y cancerígenas muchos
migrantes no acudieron al médico por
miedo a ser deportados desde ese
fatídico día rubiel aparece sinusitis
asma ansiedad y vértigos
de que la gente nueva navegando al papel
es una justicia porque se perdió lo más
preciado que la salud no hay plata que
valga si leen a 1 500 mil y un millón lo
que sea y mi plata que valgan la salud
no tiene precio como cada aniversario de
estas mujeres reivindica en su papel en
un dramático momento de la historia de
eeuu en el que ellos volvieron a ser
unos héroes sin derechos sobreviviendo
entre comillas